>>[unknown female/Interviewer]; He is an acclaimed
drummer, deejay, producer, and culinary entrepreneur,
and co-founder of The Roots, Please join me
in welcoming to Google New York,
Ahmir "?uestlove" Thompson.
[Applause]
[Cheering]
>>[Ahmir]: I, I never know if I'm allowed
to clap for myself or not.
>>[Interviewer]: You can totally "woo hoo".
>>[Ahmir]:Yay me. Yay me.
>>[Interviewer]: We do it all the time. [Audience
chuckles] Um,so I googled you...
>>[Ahmir] I love a room where everyone has
their computers.
>>[Interviewer]: Yeah, [audience chuckles]
they're all tweeting and
>>[Ahmir]: I would love to work here.
>>[Interviewer]: We're hiring...
>>[Ahmir]:Okay, I'll fill out an application.
>>[Interviewer]: I feel like we could make
that happen. Uh, what would you do here?
>>[Ahmir]:Just...search.
[Crowd and speakers laugh]
>>[Interviewer]: Just [chuckle] answer search
queries..
>>[Ahmir]: Well I don't know..after the Lego
room. How does anyone keep a job where
where there's a Lego room?
>>[Interviewer]: I don't know. That’s a
good question...it's fun right?
>>[Ahmir]: I would stay there forever. I don't
think I'd make it long here.
>>[Interviewer]: You probably would actually
because that's part of what we do.
>>[Ahmir]: Oh, okay.
>>[Interviewer]: It would work. Um, so, I
googled you, obviously.
>>[Ahmir]: Thank you.
>>[Interviewer]: Yeah. And, uh, there are
over 1.6 million results that come up.
>>[Ahmir]: That's scary.
>>[Interviewer]: Yeah. There's, it’s not
as many as Kim Kardashian though, just so
you know.
If that makes you feel better or worse, I
don't know. But....
>>[Ahmir]:Thank goodness, thank goodness.
>>[Interviewer]:I thought we'd just go through
all of them one by one.
>>[Ahmir]:Okay.
[Someone in audience giggles in a high pitch]
>>[Interviewer]:You've got nowhere to be.
The show doesn't start for hours, I think
you're
Okay.
>>[Ahmir]:I'm safe.
>>[Interviewer]:So first thing that came up
is music, obviously. And you're seen as one
of the
most inspiring, influential people in music,
having worked with everyone from D'Angelo
to Eminem to JayZ; and so I was wondering
who was the most unlikely musical inspiration
we’d find in your library.
>>[Ahmir]:Um, most unlikely?
>>[Interviewer]:Yeah, something that might
surprise me.
>>[Ahmir]:Urh....
>>[Interviewer]: If you were to invite me
over to look at your music collection..
>>[Ahmir]: I don't know. 'Cause the thing
is, I think that, in the past twenty years,
I've made a career out of
doing the exact opposite of what was expected
of me, so I would almost think that
for me to do something normal or expected
would be like the new shock. Like, would just
be like Madonna
just wore you know, did a non-controversial
project or something. I don't know. Um, who
would people
be shocked that I'm working with?
>>[Interviewer]: Well, what's an unconventional
place that you find music inspiration from?
Or just inspiration in general? You have your
fingers in so many pots, and what
sort of drives you?
>>[Ahmir]: See, it's really hard for me, because
I don't treat music as like a separate entity.
Like, oh, there's oxygen, and there's work,
and there's food, and oh here's music.
Like, music is just ..it's so...it's so ubiquitous
to me, like blood flow, I can't do
anything without sound. Um, you know, people
that follow me on Google have been
having the field day watching me curse out
Time Warner. [Audience laughs, Ahmir laughs]
And trying to court court Fios at the same
time because, uh, there's been dead silence
in my house for like the last four days and
it's, like killing me that, you know,
my cable's off but, um, I don't know. Uh,
let's see, uh, right now I'm, I'm
just discovering Tom T. Hall, uh, a country
singers, a country singer from 50's, 60's,
well I meant, once you do something it's forever,
but his era was between uh, between the 50's
and the 70's. I'll say that bluegrass is like
the one area, which I'm not well versed in,
so because I'm known to do unorthodox things
in my deejay set, you know. My niche in deejaying
is the whole
"Oh my god, he actually played that!?!" so
um I'm, I'm trying to search for a lot of
bluegrass
and country music that's like between 106
beats per minute and 120, so that way
>>[Interviewer]: Is there a lot in there?
>>[Ahmir]: I can mix and match them and shock
people. So, probably in the next month or
so.
Like I absorb it first before I do it. I don't
play a song blind like okay well I think this
works.
Like I gotta plan it, and test it and make
sure it works first.
>>[Interviewer]: So where do you buy your
records? or your CD's?
>>[Ahmir]:um...no...I still buy records. uh
[takes sharp breath] uh, um..it's it’s it's
kind of
different for me now. Um, you know, in the
beginning, there there were a lot of mom and
pop stores
that I went to in Philadelphia and then when
you start touring. Mike D's the one,
Mike D. from the Beastie Boys, um, like my
first adult, four figure record shopping spree
purchase
was due to like a record store that he recommended
to me in Portland. At first I was like
Portland, Oregon? But then he taught, he told
me like the most unlikely cities are the best
places to get
you know, because, you know, they might not
treasure it as, you know, you go to New York
City,
you're going to pay uh, three thousand dollars
for like uh, the original Beatles "Yesterday,
Today, Forever"
where they had like the uh blood on their
smocks. There was a controversial Beatles
cover like with them in
butchers’ outfits and headless dolls. That's
very expensive. [interviewer chuckles] Um,
whereas you can go to you know
Kalamazoo, Michigan and the person might not
know the value of it so you can get away with
it, so I mean.
>>[Interviewer]: So just the flight cost of
getting there...but
>>[Ahmir]:Well yeah, I meant
>>[Interviewer]: so the thrill of the hunt?
It's alright.
>>[Ahmir]:Well you get my point.[chuckles]
Um, but now I mostly, I have a broker who
will let me know when estates, have things
for sale. So, in other words, if a
disgruntled wife wants to, [audience laughs]
no like I hate to say this,
I hate to really generalize it like this but,seriously
like uh jazz collections come
from divorced women who like inherit everything
and just want to get rid of the stuff.
[soft laughter from audience and other speaker]
Um, a lot of my, again this is like [stammers
slightly] it's generalizing but
it's it's how it is like, mothers' whose sons
have passed away untimely or whatever,
Like I'll inherit "Here are these 800 hip
hop records..what do you do with it?"
Or I've had to purchase records from uh, club
deejays, from the 80's who might have
to pay their hospital bills, and that sort
of stuff.
>>[Interviewer]: A lot of depressing stories
here, divorce, death.
>>[Ahmir]:That's like right now I'm, I'm,
I'm trying to, I guess the biggest record
collection story now is, um, a hero of mine,
uh, J Dilla, um, when he made his
move to Los Angeles, he just put all his stuff
in storage, he was from Detroit, Michigan,
so he put his stuff in storage but of course,
now that he's gone, and his bills are sort
of neglected,
uh, the owner of the uh, the warehouse, or
where his stuff was stored, discovered, that
he had
J Dilla's record collection so, I'm trying
to... I don't, I don't want it sourced out
and separated,
I think that it should be put together, so
I'm, I'm trying to bid the entire
10,000 record collection so. So again, I just,
I buy people's collections that have had some
sort
of misfortune with it. [Audience chuckles]
I'll tell you a very interesting one I got.
Um, Levi Stubbs, the late lead singer of the
Four Tops,
his daughter just sold me his entire record
collection...shh,man, like he has like
>>[Interviewer]: everything?
>>[Ahmir]:His is more like historical a lot
of his stuff are acetates from like old Motown
sessions,
and things like that. Like it was like eighteen
boxes. I only opened up three of them, but
I'm sure like the
rest of them have historical artifacts in
them, so right now I'm just sitting on like
70,000 records.
>>[Interviewer]: Where do you store all this?
>>[Ahmir]: Before I bought my first house,
I, well I'll just say that my business manager's
probably one
of the smartest people on earth, you know
if, when my record collection was like kissing
20,000,
it was in my house, and then a friend of mine,
Q-tip,
lost his entire 40,000 records and and a lot
of Tribe Called Quest artifacts
in uh, uh, a fire in 1999. So that freaked
me out,
because at this point, when you were coming
into my house, there was nothing but records,
so you could just hear the theme from Indiana
Jones [hums theme from Indiana Jones] like,
and you were like, trying to jump over like
trying to figure out ways to not crush records
'cause they were just everywhere.
Um, so I built my my fantasy, my version of
the Library of Congress room.
It's like, you know, I told them like, you
know, cherry wood floors and sliding ladders.
And it's cataloged and it's beautiful. But
now it's in Philadelphia,
and I'm here so I gotta figure out what my
next move is gonna to be.
Like how to transfer that up to up to New
York.
>>[Interviewer]: Right. Well.
>>[Ahmir]: Sorry for that long answer.
>>[Interviewer]:Yeah it's pretty.
>>[Ahmir]:We gotta go, good-bye.
[laughter]
>>[Interviewer]: Thank you. Enjoy the chicken.
>>[Ahmir]: Thank you
>>[Interviewer]: It's, speaking of the chicken,
so people have been wondering
why is ?uestlove coming in under the guise
of the Chefs at Google...
>>[Ahmir, chuckling]: I know, like people...
>>[Interviewer]: like what?
>>[Ahmir]: Who's head scratching like? [People
laughing] Rawr?
>> [Interviewer]: That was the sound that
they made actually. Explaining that road,
from the Grammy's to the kitchen.
>>[Ahmir]: Um, I guess the short story is
that uh, um, doing two hundred shows at night,
um, with the Roots, means doing an additional
two hundred deejay gigs. Two hundred shows
a night?
[Interviewer chuckles]
>>[Interviewer]: That's a lot of shows...
>> [Ahmir]: Yeah, we all...
>> [Interviewer]: We weren't going to correct
you...
>> [Ahmir]: Thank you, but that dismays me
that you guys weren't going to correct me.
[Interviewer chuckles]
Um, doing two hundred shows a year also means
that I have to do two hundred deejay gigs
a year.
And I've noticed in the northwestern part
of the United States: Seattle, Portland, Utah,
those
places have very interesting presentation
set ups. Sort of like how you guys have a
truck
inside your cafeteria. I'll say that food
truck culture, which is a very big thing
in Philadelphia really hit its creative, at
least in my eyes, its stride in like 2002
where
you know, two in the morning, these guys were
selling any and every thing.
Like the first time I ever saw an all grilled
cheese truck was outside of a deejay gig in
Portland.
And then one guy had a real specialty truck,
it was like, was nothing but corn, and I thought,
but no,
people would lined up like it was...
>>[Interviewer]: They were all drunk. That’s
why...[chuckles] we want corn...
>> [Ahmir]: But no, it was like he was from
the 50's "hear ye, hear ye, get your corn!
Get your corn! Get your corn!"
And I was like, what the hell is he selling?
But he sold like a vast array of corn.
So cut to like me, no, uh one was like dipped
in honey, one was Mexican corn.
>>[Interviewer]: Honey corn?
>>[Ahmir]: Yo, it was honey, it was dipped
in honey and then coconut, like...
>>[Interviewer]: That sounds awfully disgusting.
>>[Ahmir]: like chocolate covered..
>>[Interviewer]: Chocolate covered corn?
>>[Ahmir]: Wait, where's Darryl at?
>>[Man yells] Over here.
>>[Ahmir]: Shut up man, that's a trick.
>> [Interviewer]: That's his trainer who's
here. He's not happy about the chocolate covered
corn.
>> [Ahmir]: Anyway, no, it was like really
creative how they did it. And I always wanted
to have
like my soul food version of a like Mr. Softees
truck. Back then, I thought, Okay, I'm gonna
have this thing called "Soul on a Roll".[laughter]
And you know, but I couldn't
execute half of these ideas because we had
to commit to you know two hundred nights.
When you're only in your hometown for three
months out of the year, there's really no
stability,
not domestically or anything so once, once
the Jimmy Fallon show came along, and offered
us
normalcy, for the, like we started the Roots
as nineteen and twenty year olds. Now, we're
forty. So imagine, just going from high school
and then now is the second year that I know
what normal life is like.
Or at least a semblance of what like an every
day routine is like. So this very new to me,
so I feel like I'm that
twenty year older that's dreaming about, let
me try this and let me, I'm just wanting to
try new ideas out, so
I guess with the Drumstick, that was the most
obvious choice to develop it.
We developed it for like, I guess a year.
Having a lot of taste tests.
I put it out on Twitter that I was looking
for a chef,
and I guess people assumed I just wanted a
personal
>>[Interviewer]: Right
>> [Ahmir]: Like I have some sort of kingdom
and [Ahmir chuckles] so a lot of people
submitted, over nine hundred people submitted
videos, and I , uh, and then we
somehow managed to do a lot of focus groups
and taste test and contests,
not contests but you know trying out a bunch
of dishes and then we were
finally satisfied, I guess, a year later enough
to start our venture.
And this is a very slow, I don't believe in
that whole skipping the bank line,
and just going instantly to Boardwalk and
Park Place, without having
to go through Oriental Avenue, Virginia States,
and Marvin's Gardens. Like I want
to slowly travel it, so you know you start,
you start with the blogosphere first,
and then you cook for other chefs, and then
you come to places like Google
and other conglomerates and then you slowly
build your way up. And so this is.
>> [Interviewer]: I was telling you, the James
Beard Awards were just announced last night,
and I have to say, we've done a pretty good
job of curating Chefs at Google,
if I do say so myself, because half the people
that we've had in the last year
were winners last night, so no pressure.
[audience chuckles]
>> [Ahmir]: Who won last night?
>> [Interviewer]: Hugh Atchison, um
>> [Ahmir]: Okay, okay...
>> [Interviewer]: Daniel Hung was outstanding
chef, so no pressure but
>> [Ahmir]: Ah, it's no pressure.
>> [Interviewer]: It's within your reach.
>> [Ahmir]: I mean the, the fact that renown
seven times winner James Beard Award winning
chef tries
to challenge me, like he's an MC.
>> [Interviewer]: Yeah so let's talk about
that. How did, what, how did happen?
>> [Ahmir]: That's as big an honor.
>> [Interviewer]: David Chang challenged him
to a fried chicken battle...
>> [Ahmir]: Yeah, David Chang. Yeah, at first
I thought "ha ha that Chang, he's, he's cute"
you know, but then, it was like everyone kept
asking:Yo, why has Chang been pickin' on you?
Like, I mean, we just, we created such a buzz
and I guess that people were just,
I don't know, maybe the best way to go through
life is to be, I love being underestimated,
you know?
And I guess that his thoughts were like, really,
I'm tired of hearing people rave about about
your food or whatever, and so then, you know,
I was forced to just say bring it on.
So, my show got involved by "staging" "a battle."
I'm being very "diplomatic" now.
>>[Interviewer]: Do you feel like it was rigged,
just a little bit?
>> [Ahmir]: NO comment. Uh, he was nervous
though. Yeah, and so he, uh, he really put
a lot of preparation
into it so I mean the fact, I mean in a way
I'm glad I, I'm glad I kinda lost because
I think that if the news
got out that you know, a drummer from West
Philly beats a seven time James Beard Award
winning chef, then, you know
>>[Interviewer]: Let's kill an industry.
>> [Ahmir]: The world would have been, every
chef nobody would have touched me so.
Uh, no, I consider it an honor, and you know,
he's a friend and I
believe that
[speaking to someone off stage] Alexis when
does it go into uh,
>>[someone off stage]: May 20th
>>[Ahmir]: Yeah, he's agreed to serve the
Drumsticks at Momofuku on May 20th.
>> [Interviewer]: On May 20th, in case you
didn't get one here.
>> [Ahmir]: Yeah.
>> [Interviewer]: Um, so we're at a tech company
obviously, and I would love to know what's
the most profound way
technology has changed your life? If you were
starting out, if the Roots were starting today..
>> [Ahmir]: You you know something ..
>> [Interviewer]: Would things be different
for you?
>> [Ahmir]: I'll honestly say that we were
the last, I believe, honestly believe, that
we were the last group to really
get on the caboose of what the old standard
was. 'Cause I think that, back then there
was
there was visions of technology and, remember,
there was talk of the super information highway
and that type of stuff. Like we came right
in on the caboose, which was, you know, I
guess the world
knew of us in '94, I mean we started in '92,
but the world became aware of us in '94.
But, I, too, wonder what would happen, because
I think the thing that made us work hard and
made us
so resilient was the fact that there was absolutely
no outlets. We, what's the term English people
use,
when you...Busking. We were busking, the term
busking is when you put the shoe box on the
street,
and you play on buckets and people throw money
in there. That's the route that we went to.
Now, if we started twenty years later, we
would just have made a whole bunch of YouTube
videos.
I don't think we would have worked as hard
if we had the technology that's available
to us today.
So, I'm almost glad that we came right before
the technology age really started to, to grow.
Because a lot of people always ask,well, how
are you able to work at Fallon, produce this
record,
score this film, do these shoes, and now fried
chicken, da da da duh. Like all these things,
there's just a work ethic that we've had,
like a sink or swim thing that I don't think
we'd have had had we grown up in the technology
era.
>> [Interviewer]: So now...
>> [Ahmir]: BUT it's helped us.
>> [Interviewer]: Yeah [chuckles] so you are
one of the most prolific Tweeters as many
of us know who do follow you.
>> [Ahmir]: Thank you.
>> [Interviewer]: Um, why is connecting to
your audience through social media in that
way so important to you?
[Ahmir chuckles softly]
I don't know why that's a funny question.
>> [Ahmir]: No, well, 'cause you know, this
is the point of the day where I, you know,
take the pin and I take the balloon,
and ssss...and deflate it. 'Cause people ask,
how do you tweet so much, how do you da da
da duh.
First of all, I mean tweeting is just a, it's
just a running dialog, and it takes me literally
ten seconds to get a
thought out. I think people think it's like
some rocket science thing where I have to
sit and
take, take an hour out to think of something,
but you know, I can easily, you know, drum
on.
All the time at Fallon, yesterday, when the
Beach Boys were on, I mean I was playing music
and
>> [Interviewer]: Tweeting...
>> [Ahmir]: and tweeting at the same time.
I don't know. I just see it as ongoing communication,
I mean it started
with my, when, when I developed our website
Okayplayer.com I wanted, I noticed that no
one hip hop was really,
with the exception of, the exception of the
Beastie Boys, sometimes with with with, on
Hole's website, Courtney Love's
group Hole, and maybe with REM's website,
in the mid, in the late 90's, those were the
only artists I saw kind of above the radar
that were actively communicating with their
fan base. Then the artists that I really loved,
like A Tribe Called Quest,
the only personal thing you knew about them
was Q-tips favorite spaghetti recipe or Lauryn
Hill loves Jamaican food mon.
Like that was on her website. And yes, the
word "mon" was in there like "mon". You know
so, back in 98, I wanted to
revolutionize, or think I was revolutionizing,
that velvet rope, in cutting it. So maybe
like the first year,
of that website, you know, you had to get
over the whole novelty of "Oh my God, it's
really you ?uestlove" and that type
of thing. So after doing Okayplayer for twelve
years in which I've absolutely spilled everything,
like
there's no need to write a book, you just
need to go to the history of all my postings
on that website.
Something like Twitter comes along, it just
forces you to give concise answers, as opposed
to long, drawn out answers
like I'm doing right now to you, so
>> [Interviewer]: Can you compose a Tweet
for me? about the last meal you had?
>> [Ahmir]: Shut up Darryl. Ha ha. I had salad,
end Tweet.
>> [Interviewer]: Okay, so can we do a word
association?
>> [Ahmir]: Sure.
>> [Interviewer]: Alright, I want you to just
tell me whatever comes to mind when I say
the following words. Ready?
[laughter from audience]
I haven't even started yet.
Okay, food trucks?
>> [Ahmir]: The future.
>> [Interviewer]: Prince?
>> [Ahmir]: God.
>> [Interviewer]: Cupcakes.
>> [Ahmir]: Darryl.
[audience laughs]
>> [Interviewer]: Jimmy Fallon?
>> [Ahmir]: Genuine.
>> [Interviewer]: Little nervous too right?
A little sweaty?
>> [Ahmir]: No. He, he...
>> [Interviewer]: I'm just kidding...I'm totally
messing with you. Chicken?
>> [Ahmir]: That was first year Jimmy. Now
he's he's cool as a cucumber.
>> [Interviewer]: Chicken?
>> [Ahmir]: Hmm...uh, profit.
[audience laughs. Applause]
>> [Interviewer]: David Chang?
>> [Ahmir]: Revenge. [Ahmir chuckles]
[Audience laugh loudly]
>> [Interviewer]: Alright, just a couple more
questions for you, then we'll open it up to
Q and A.
>> [Ahmir]: Sure.
>> [Interviewer]: If you could request any
Google Doodle, what would it be?
>> [Ahmir]: My, I've, I've been stalking Google
to do a Commemorative Soul Train Doodle for
the longest, well, I I don't know that people
who follow me on Twitter know that I'm religious
with Google Doodles
'cause I don't know, it's just fun and you
know, it's like looking at a puzzle and I'm
trying
to figure out, okay, how's it amalgamated
and inside the "O" and the "O" and where's
the "L", I enjoy it. A lot.
Like, when I wake up, that's the first thing
I look to see, if anything has happened.
>> [Interviewer]: There's a new one everyday.
>> [Ahmir]: I'm a geek, I'm sorry. Yeah, so
that would, would be that's my favorite, and
now that it's interactive,
more than ever, I've been Tweeting profusely
about a Soul Train Doodle.
>> [Interviewer]: Okay, well. I don't have
a Soul Train Doodle for you. However, when
the team in California found out, look at
that smile,
when they found out you were coming, one of
our Doodlers is a huge fan, Ryan Germick,
and it happens to be his birthday today,
by coincidence. And..
>> [Ahmir]: Happy birthday
>> [Interviewer]: he's on VC somewhere, hopefully.
Hi, Ryan. He sent a little present over for
you.
>> [Ahmir]: That's so awesome man.
[clapping and laughter from audience]
Thank you!
Ha haa..this is like everything that I love
in this one thing, like I'm wearing a Prince
t-shirt, I'm playing drums,
I have a drumstick in one hand and Lego heart,
and I'm holding the letter "L". That is awesome.
>> [Interviewer]: You like it? It's pretty
good right?
>> [Ahmir]: Wait, can I Tweet that?
>> [Interviewer]: You can Tweet that.
>> [Ahmir]: I'm allowed to?
>> [Interviewer]: But we're going to move
onto the next question, because I know you
have to move on.
>> [Ahmir]: I can tweet and talk to you at
the same time.
>> [Interviewer]: Alright, so you can Tweet
and talk. So you told me earlier that the
last thing you searched for
Bruce Almighty. There's a story there, and
we'll explain it at some point, but I was
wondering if you
could slow down the search results for me?
[audience chuckles]
No pressure, I'm going to look it up right
now.
>> [Ahmir]: Okay, you're going to look up
Bruce Almighty?
>> [Interviewer]: Bruce Almighty.
>> [Ahmir]: Mm hmm.
>> [Interviewer]: Bear with me, we're going
to this while you Tweet, if I have a cell
signal. Alright, you ready?
>> [Ahmir]: Yes.
>> [Interviewer]: Are you still Tweeting or
..
>> [Ahmir]: Do we get...uh, no. I sent twelve
out already.
>> [Interviewer]: During the, during the talk?
>> [Ahmir]: Yeah.
>> [Interviewer]: You were just doing it in
your pocket? Are you ready?
>> [Ahmir]: Is the mike here? Okay.
>> [Interviewer]: Alright, okay. Bruce Almighty,
2003, IMDB.
>>[Ahmir whispers]: Okay
[normal voice] Wait. Can we get more ambiance?
Can we turn the lights down?
>> [Interviewer]: Do we need a beat? We need
mood lighting?
>> [Ahmir]: Do we have any music? Any slow
music? Shut up Darryl.
>> [Interviewer]: Are we throwing down a beat?
>> [Ahmir]: Wait, they're turning down all
the lights over ...[laughs loudly]
>> [Interviewer]: They turned the lights over
there.
>> [Ahmir]: Okay, this is already a fail.
Okay.
>> [Interviewer]: We're going to start again.
We're going to do it again.
>>[Ahmir whispers]okay.
>> [Interviewer]: You ready?
>>[Ahmir whispers]: I'm ready
>> [Interviewer]: Bruce Almighty, 2003, IMDB
>>[Ahmir,low voice] Oh, yeah. She loves Jimmy
Cary. This is gonna be a fail.
>> [Interviewer]: Bruce Almighty, Wikipedia,
the free encyclopedia.
>> [Ahmir]: [breathes heavily] She's trusting
enough to go to an unreliable source of encyclopedia...
Wait, can I just say that I don't agree that
Wikipedia is all that revisionist. Anyway.
>> [Interviewer]: Images for Bruce Almighty.
>> [Ahmir]: I forgot why I searched Bruce
Almighty.
>> [Interviewer]: We were talking about um,
Bill Gates being the Moses of the Silicon
Valley and uh..
>> [Ahmir]: We just got super non-sequitered
now.
>> [Interviewer]: and then he went into Bruce
Almighty. I don't know why. I just went with
it.
Bruce Almighty, Rotten Tomatoes.
>> [Ahmir]: Can we talk about Bruce Almighty
two?
>> [Interviewer]: Sure.
>> [Ahmir]: Such a shame baby that you only
got a 27 rating.
>> [Interviewer]: Awesome, thank you [claps]
You're a good sport.
>> [Ahmir]: Steve Carrell has no future. Nah,
I'm playing. [laughs] I'm bad at slow Jamming.
I'm sorry.
>> [Interviewer]: Nah, that's pretty good.
>> [Ahmir]: Thank you.
>> [Interviewer]: That wasn't bad. We're going
to open it up to Q and A. And if you guys
have any questions, if you can
go to one of the two standing mikes, because
we're recording this for YouTube.
>>[male audience member]: Hi [clears throat]
>>[Ahmir]: Howdy
>>[male audience member]: Hi, my name is Jesus.
I'm an engineer, uh, you started around '92
with the Roots,
a time where like, mostly, uh, you should
go through a, a record company to get your
album out there. Nowadays,
any kiddo can buy like a three thousand dollar
computer, have a studio at home, and then
like release an album. What is
your point of view from an era, from a time
era where you had to like get put out there,
to a time era where
there's so much out there, that it's very
difficult to find things?
>>[Ahmir]: It's, it's funny you say that,
because um, a friend of mine, a fellow Philadelphian,
a rapper, Meek Mills, whose
down with Rick Ross, just released his mix
tape yesterday. 2.5 million downloads in one
day, which, you know,
in layman’s terms, he just went almost triple
platinum in a 24 hour period. So it's kinda
hard to determine,
I know like RIAA sales determine what success
is, well like 500,000 people will purchase
this then you get a gold plaque, but
what does that say about the three million
people that now have his music as well? Which,
you know,
I know that RIAA, and a few artists are arguing
that well, you know, that's doing a disservice
to the industry,
because the artists aren't getting paid, but,
you know, I'm almost certain that if he's
able to go triple platinum
in a twenty four hour period, then that means,
if he were to do a show or a concert in the
next week or so, it would instantly sell out,
or could do a bigger venue and somehow, like
that to me is like the
monetary reward that he would get, probably
more than, like, I've never depended on record
sales for any type
of money, like a lot of my money is based
on everything but making records. Like, I
consider
making records sorta like the person outside
the club that hands you fliers at the end
of the night to let you know
when another club is open, or who's there
next week. Like that's what I use records
for. So, I mean yeah,
the industry has changed, whether or not the
RIAA continues its mission, especially with,
you know, the Sopa controversy,
Like it remains to be seen, but you know,
I think that there's going to have to be a
changing of the guards.
And you know, the recording industry in America
is holding on to dear life, you know, and
it's so obvious that a new system
has to start.
>>[Jesus]: If you Tweet the link to the album
and he has a PayPal, I'm sure that, I mean
if I like the music, I'd put some money there
too, so.
>>He's rich enough.
[Laughter]
Who's up?
>>[female audience member]: Hi, um...
>>[Ahmir]: Oh, wow,
>>[female audience member]: My turn?
>> [Ahmir]: You guys are good...it's like
magic . Wee ooo...
>>[female audience member]: Hi, um, I used
to live in Philly, and I was hoping
you could talk about some of your favorite
Philly restaurants.
>>[Ahmir]: Yeah
>>[female audience member]: and just favorite
restaurants in general. And also I work in
Sigad,
>>[Ahmir]: Oh nice.
>>[female audience member]..up on the ninth
floor and you could stop by later and you
know, visit there..
>> [Ahmir]: Sure.
>>[female audience member]: we could just
sorta hang out.
>> [Ahmir]: What part of Philly?
>>[female audience member]: I lived in Northern
Liberties...
>>[Ahmir]: Oh, that's where I live, well,
that's where my home is, my current home is.
>>[female audience member]: Yeah, I saw you
at Honey's once actually, at brunch.
>>[Ahmir uses sing song voice]: Stalking me....
[laughter bursts from the crowd]
[Ahmir in normal voice]: Uh, I'll be honest
with you, close your ears Darryl, I chose
my house because
it was in walking distance to Honey's,
[crowd laughs]
>>[female audience member]: I love Honey's,
that's a good reason to choose to live there.
>>[Ahmir]: Um, no actually, um, Philadelphia
is probably the last easily affordable cosmopolitan
city,
in the United States. In the terms of, you
know, property, and and resources, and you
know,
I still miss it a lot, I mean, I'm not saying
that I'm a 100% New Yorker, but I'll just
say
that, you know, last time I was in Philadelphia
was like a long time ago. But, um,
you know, I, I , I like that area of Northern
Liberties, because it's it's like our version
of
maybe Williamsburg.
>>[female audience member]: yeah
>> [Ahmir]: You know, a lot of like mom and
pop, well, what would you call a mom and pop
store
that's not a mom and pop store? Mom and pop
makes it sound so country like. It's it's
just a lot
of non-corporate businesses.
>>[Interviewer]: Local
>> [Ahmir]: Local, there you go. That's, that's
what I was searching for. There's a lot of
local
restaurants so, that whole area. Yeah, I love
it, and I'll keep that house forever.
>>[female audience member]: Come to Sigad.
>>[Ahmir]: Okay.
>>[male audience member]: What's up ?uest?
My name is Jilani, and I'm a tech consultant
here,
and also a long time okayplayer.
>>[Ahmir] Oh, alright.
>>[Jilani]: And, I was thinking back to what
you said earlier about when the Roots came
out,
uh, I remember back to "Do You Want More,"
and just thinking about how things have changed
now,
and you said you felt like it might be a little
easier for people with Internet to get their
message out.
But I wonder if it's, if you think it's also
more challenging just because there's so much
material and the number of videos?
>>[Ahmir]: My manager told me that he had
a precise number, that there are...in existence
I think right now,
there's there's a site in which you actually
know the amount of unique mp3's that are on,
as far as songs on the Internet, and the,
the number was close to, I think he said,
like seventeen million unique songs created
on the Internet, of which only 29%, a very
small percent, even get heard. Like a lot
of kids create it,
put in on the Internet, and no downloads whatsoever.
Um yeah, I think that the the floodgates,
and sort of the overabundance of information,
that sort of makes it harder to, like there's
so much
information out there as far as music is concerned,
and you know, it becomes overwhelming. Like
there's a record store
that I shop at in Pittsburgh called Jerry's,
you literally, you have to plan a four day
trek out there, because,
I'll start at ten, when I go there I'll go
there at like ten in the morning, by the time
he closes at eight, I might
get to the letter "C". That's how large, it's
like the largest warehouse of records ever.
So, I mean it's problematic,
which is why you sorta have to supplement
what you do with other forms to promote, you
know, what you do. So.
>>[Jilani]: Just one quick follow up also,
>> [Ahmir]: Sure.
>>[Jilani]: can you talk a little about how
your own website has helped
launch a few careers? Like I remember Little
Brother, and Tonya Morgan, and etc.
>> [Ahmir]: Yeah, um, you know, I mean the
whole idea of okayplayer was to just, I guess,
provide a playground, for like mind, I wanted,
I wanted to just talk music with a bunch of
people that I felt spoke my language. And
so, you know of course, under the guise of
the Roots albums then you know, I figured
that's where our fan base was,
and then, after about a year or so of of getting
through that whole awkwardness "Is this really
you, ?uest?"
Now, you know, two years into it, they felt
like they knew me and then we could,
like, some of those guys I really consider,
like, you know, I'm. I'm the student and they're
the teachers.
You know there's at least five or six guys
on there to whom, they're like my cabinet
members, even with my
walk on songs for Fallon, they're the ones,
you know, "Why don't ya try this one?" or
"Why don't ya try this one?"
You know, like, that site's very necessary.
It's like a music geek's, uh, haven.
I mean some of them are shock posters of course,
you know, it's like, well, you know, "Prince
has seen his heyday back in 1992, after" You
know, they'll do shock posting, but, for the
most part, um, it's still to me
a very credible source of ..it's like a, it's
like a nice Pitchfork.
[laughter]
Sorry Pitchfork.
>>[male audience member]: Alright, ?uest,
again I'm like a huge fan of yours, going
way back. I'm old enough to
be like organic style, but I followed you
through uh, you know Betty Wright, and Philadelphia
Experiment, and
>> [Ahmir]: Oh, thanks.
>>[male audience member]: Soul Power Mix Tape,
and all that good stuff. Uh, I can remember
when the Roots first
were really getting a buzz, I was happy because
I thought ya know, hip hop was gonna all of
a sudden, go in this more instrumental,
musical direction and, you know, y’all are,
obviously, ubiquitous and have, you know,
changed the industry as much as it would
be possible to do. But I wondered whether
you thought towards the future, you know,
not now, you got a lot of stuff going on,
but towards like education, cause I've been
exposed to a lot of music from being a fan
of yours and following you, and, and I think
that you've got a lot of, uh, steam behind
you to, to encourage people to broaden their
musical horizons and take a more historical
view.
>> [Ahmir]: Yeah, I thought that we would
spawn, and I think that speculation was like,
okay, we'll, we'll, we'll spawn a lot of bands.
Not the case, I think mostly because, again,
with us being the last band that was allowed,
not even allowed. I mean I'll, I guess I could
be, be honest. Because of the bidding war
situation that we were in with our record
label, we negotiate, instead of like, you
know, a lot of people like, when they're in
a bidding war, when like, labels are fighting
over each other, um, mostly people go for
the money. And my managers and lawyers decided
to go for the longevity. So, because, because
music was so disposable at the time, whereas,
like, okay, you're only good for your one
hit, and then later for you, they organized
it so that we could never get dropped for
a long period of time. Like, cause really,
there's really no reason, like if you look
at it, I mean we've had two, well, I meant
and we had two very, we had like four slow
Gold Records, but, I mean most people see
it as, okay, Things Fall Apart and Phrenology,
our fourth and fifth album, as like our success
story. But there's really no reason why a
group with like not one dance hit, like we
never had like a hip hop jam, has lasted for
twenty years, this long with fifteen albums
under its belt, you know, surpassing the time,
time line of people I consider, like, you
know, like major hip hop contributors, um,
like there's just no logical reason for us
to have been here. A big part of it was that,
the way our contract was built, artist development
was a very important thing, and that's, that's
the problem with the industry now, like, they
don't believe in the long run of, okay, we'll
place you here now and then maybe by album
number five, you know, you'll have a following,
they don't believe in that, it's still, just,
it's very disposable. We need it now, we need
it quick-fast, in a hurry, just add water,
poof, uh, no, see you later, goodbye. And
then they dispose of you. So, I'm, I'm, I'm
very thankful that my management and my lawyers,
orchestrated it so that, you know, if we made
album number one, we had to have made two,
three, and four, and then if we got to album
number five, we were forced to do six, seven,
and eight, and if we made it to album number
nine, ten, eleven, twelve. I mean, now we're
golden, but back then they would've easily
dropped us at, before Things Fall Apart, you
know, before we became realized.
>>[Interviewer] So what's the lesson here
?uestlove? Everybody needs a good lawyer is
the lesson? [crowd laughs Important words
for all of us.
>>[male audience member] I did, I said I was
a lawyer, right?
>>[Interviewer] Yeah, he is a lawyer.
[crowd laughs]
>>[Ahmir laughs]: Everyone's a lawyer here!
>>[Interviewer] Everybody's a lawyer, everybody's
a lawyer, everybody, yeah.
>>[Ahmir]: Even the custodian goes, "yeah,
we're lawyers."
[crowd laughs]
>>[Interviewer] Um, I think we have time for
one more quick question.
>> [Ahmir]: I don't care if I miss rehearsal.
Go ahead.
>>[someone offstage] Oooh...
>>[Interviewer] Alright, then we have time
for two.
>>[Ahmir] I'm only playing NBC. Go ahead.
[laughter]
>> Hey ?uest, my name is Brian, I do music
research for YouTube, I just have a question.
>>[Ahmir] And you're a lawyer?
>>[Brian] No.
>>[Ahmir]: Okay.
>>[Brian] God, no.
[laughter]
>> [Ahmir]: So I just had a question, just
about, you know, the artists that you've worked
with over the years, like, in particular,
like the Soulquarians, like just working with
J.D.
>>[Ahmir] Mm-hm.
>> In particular. I'm a huge fan of his, and...
>>[Ahmir] Thanks.
>> So um, and I really hope you get that entire
lot, that'd be amazing. Uh, so uh, yeah, just
about the creative process, and, just, you
know, interacting with the guys, really, you
know, getting into the nuts and bolts, and
really
>>[Ahmir] Um...
>> Hashing things out.
>> [Ahmir]: Well, uh, see, I don't want to
be like the, everyone has theirs, their side
of the story of how it happened,
>>[Brian] Mm.
>>[Ahmir] Um, I'll just say that I'm probably
the, the, the member of my group, along with
my manager, Richard Nichols, like we, we tended
to see the scientific method of how things
work, and you know in the beginning we were
head scratching because we thought like okay
we're, we're something new and it wasn't just
enough to be like, you know, we would get
a lot of "oh I like you guys, but I don't
like rap but I like you guys" or "I hate Dr.
Dre and Snoop Dog and that's why I like you
guys." I mean I don't want to be the person
that, that's like just liking a girl because
she's beautiful, but then like okay, once
age catches on, when she's 50 and then you're
done with her because you had nothing else
in common, you don't want to start your relationship
with someone just because they hate the status
quo. Um, so we were kind of head scratching
on why we really weren't catching on in that
particular market place. I mean a big part
of it had to do with the fact
that with Dr. Dre's The Chronic, you know,
that was the first time that a credible hip
hop artist actually created a product
that sold in the millions, as opposed to you
know, like the platinum, multi-platinum success
of hip hop had to do
with artists that you were like, eh, well
they're not as good as Rock Em, or you know,
this was this, The Chronic was like the first
credible album that had massive appeal. And
thus, unfortunately, as with most things in
hip hop, when something has mass appeal, then
everything else has to clone it, and then
it gets over saturated.
Um, so we were kind of odd, we were the odd
man out. Even though we made that caboose,
we kind of missed the front of the train,
which would have been De La Sol, The Jungle
Brothers, Tribe Called Quest, Arrested Developments,
like a kind of closed with Diggable Planets.
We kind of narrowly made it to that caboose
that left the station. And after our third
album, Illadelph Half Life, we were kind of
fearing, cause album number four was coming
up, and you already know our contract structure.
If we didn't make it happen by number four,
then we might not get number five. So we had
to make something happen and because we were
on a label, swimming in money, from the legacy
of Nirvana and Guns and Roses and Aerosmith,
we're on Geffen Records. We did a presentation.
We told them that nobody has success in music
unless it's contextualized with another product.
So in other words, if you look at Motown,
there's Stevie Wonder, Diana Ross and the
Supremes, The Temptations, Marvin Gaye, like
that's a movement. Even the stuff you feel
indifferent about like let's say the disco
movement, you associate. Let's take Casablanca
Records, like The Village People, The Ritchie
Family. I like the Bee Gees, so I don't want
to say like I consider the Bee Gees like throw
away disco, but you get the point. That post
Saturday Night Fever thing. Like today, like
everyone's grouped you think of diggy music,
you think of oh Puffy, Little Kim, Foxy Brown,
JayZ, So, everything is contextualized and
sort of in a movement and the one thing we
notice that we didn't have was a movement.
We didn't have anybody, so we told them, in
order for you guys, you guys are spending
a lot of money on us. In order for you guys
to really see the monetary results you want
to see, you're going to have to invest in
a movement. Now you've already invested six
years into us. What do you want to do? And
they, they decided to, in a rare move, bite
the bullet and that was like a major ten million
dollar investment. They had to buy Common
out of his contract, of Relativity. Then we
just pointed the way. Alright, get Blackstar,
so they bought, they bought [unintelligible]
out of his thing,
they gave Dilla his own record label with
MCA. We were trying to get Slum Village, but
that time Slum village signed Interscope.
And then the rest of the people we we either
just kidnapped. So, D'Angelo and I were like
two peas in a pod. By that point I had been
on my second year of working on Voodoo which
was a five year process. So being with D'Angelo
pulled in his, his kind of label, made Erica
Badu and working with her, and then pulling
in Palau. Next thing you know, like we're
all just working with each other.
So, I'll say that at D'angelo's studio on,
on 8th avenue, 6th street, Electric Lady.
That was our epicenter from like 1996 to like
2002. We had that entire building on lock
down so it was kind of crazy because you know,
we go in in the morning. Usually, like D'Angelo
is the type of person who is like you know
I'll show up at 1 o’clock but you know that
means like 8pm. So in the third week of that
you know Common is like you know I'm doing
my record, so can we work together, so Common
who's extremely responsible and so, like he
would come in from 9 in the morning and leave
around 6pm or 7pm. So we'd work in the same
studio with Common in the morning. And then
D'Angelo from 7pm till mmm, usually [groan]
I'll say 6 in the morning. Yeah. And this
happened over and over.
And then you know, once it just became like
a big, giant sleepover, it's like college.
Because it wasn't just us working and "okay,
what songs are we going to work on." You come
there, and this is before the age of YouTube,
so a lot of people were sending me video performances
of like, Al Greene in concert and we'd sit
and watch that forever and over analyze it.
Then this Prince concert from 82 and then
you know I started acquiring my Soul Train
collection. And you know, cut to a year later,
we have an entire, like, I was like, I was,
I was, I was a walking YouTube. Like anything
that you can search on now for YouTube from
old soul clips, I had that stuff. And we would
just watch it and watch it and watch it and
study and watch it and watch it and watch
and watch it. And then go and create music.
Eat. And then watch it and watch it and watch
it and watch it and watch it.
And then eventually, you know, after five
years of working, then all of our albums come
out and then next thing you know, what the
Roots are going platinum? Ergo by Blues comes
out, D'Angelo's album comes out, Common's
album comes out, it just became a family vibe
and, and you know, that's probably one of
the best creative moments of, of, of, of my
career. Just like working in that environment.
And you know, it's sometimes, and you know
every day it wasn't a parade. Like some days
we'd have you know, the, the day that Dilla
discovered Madlib was one of the funniest
moments. Cause I'll say out of all of us,
J Dilla, was like, like he was like our guru.
He'll play like he's the underling, I don't
play drums like you, or I don't play keyboards
like him, but he was, he was like our guru.
Like we patterned our whole movement after
him. And one day he came in and he's like
"Yo, dog, like I don't know man." I'm like
what? "This album came out last week called
Lootpack." Yeah? He's like, "This producer
named Madlib, I don't know, I got to go back
to Detroit." And like he left for, like he
was really depressed. Like there's some other
guy out there that makes crazy beats, crazier
than me. And like that's how he works. Like
he just works 8 hours a day doing beats, doing
beats and so, I mean eventually they pair
it up and became friends. But before it was
a problem, he just felt like O my god like,
threatened, I met my match. So, sorry for
this long drawn out story. He's enjoying it,
but, yeah
>>[Brian]: Thank you, thank you so much.
>>[Ahmir]: Yeah, you're welcome.
>>[female audience member]: I feel like he's
been waiting a long time. Yeah you're sure?
I don't want to get you in trouble at NBC.
>>[male audience member]: My name's Isaiah
I'm an engineer here, big time fan. Same thing.
And that also sounds like the life. Kinda
just chillin', watching soul videos and making
music so that's awesome. But my question is
about, basically, you talked about the mix
tape culture we've got and also kind of like
the retail culture how those are kind of like
two separate things, and it's a pretty old
conversation to talk about you know, underground
versus mainstream. But why, what is it from
an artists' perspective, like recently you
have Buster signing to MMG, you've got Q-Tip
signing to Good Music. Why do artists feel
now that they still have to be part of these
movements when someone like Meat can sell
2.5 in a day. Why do artists feel drawn to.
>> [Ahmir]: Independence is probably the scariest
thing. Cause even you know, as far as monetary
terms are concerned, like again, like having
a record deal might be still in my top 10,
only because I am a record collector, do I
cherish having a record deal. And I enjoy
the fact that I've been on the same label
for the whole time so you know, I, I do have
those moments where I look at my catalog and
I see the same font for every Roots logo and
it's like wow that's really incredible, I
made 15 records, like these are my 15 kids.
I can't speak for those other artists, but
I think for some artists in particular, the
idea of having a plan B is a very frightening
option.
Like it's almost like getting a needle at
the doctor. Like I used to hate, I used to,
I still hate getting needles. Quick story.
The last time I was at the dentist was like
maybe 20 years ago. [laughter] Seriously.
And so because I had a really bad Novocaine
experience with like a student dentist in
like 1979 or something. So I stayed away.
And of course you know you can't last in life
20 years not going to the dentist. And of
course, people are like Ahmir you don't understand,
technology has changed, they have these things
called butterfly needles, you'll never feel
it. And of course you know my fear of like
"no no" but of course like now I can't eat
food because my teeth are about to fall out.
Of course I go to the dentist and you know,
I'm like closing my eyes and bracing myself.
Alright let me know when it happens. He's
like "I already put it in." No, seriously!
[Ahmir snores] And then you know it's like
I never felt it.
So it's like the fear of the unknown sometimes
cripples you. And again, because of the time
that we came out, we had to do five times
the work of the average artist. Like when
we came out, people weren't rolling out the
red carpet, they weren't welcoming us with
open arms. They were like you guys are corny.
You aren't a real rap group. You don't even
have a real deejay, literally, you know, you're
doing all this jazz stuff and like whatever,
it took, we, it took us so long to get their
respect. And once an audience did embrace
us who wasn't the prime hip hop audience,
we had to learn how to entertain them. That
said, I'll say that having a plan B, like
I've done everything under the, I know this
is negative to say, but sort of under the
assumption that this is not going to work,
so let me do something else. You know, even
this Fallon gig. People are like "Oh man,
you guys finally got the exposure you want."
You know what I am thinking about? Conan O'Brien.
[laughter]
No, because Conan, Conan, Conan was still
shooting his show across the hall the first
year and you know, I saw everything, the whole
staff and yeah "So you guys excited for California?"
Oh my God, oh, I can't wait, I just sold my
house, it's a little risky, but Conan all
talked to us, took us all out to dinner. I
just sold my house and I can't wait to go
to California it's going to be exciting. You
know, cut to nine months later and that's
like my worst nightmare. Now, personally me,
I"m always having a plan E, plan F, plan G.
Like I never plan on anything being final.
So that said, and again I'm sorry for the
long drawn out explanation. I just think that,
you know, that some artists are just set in
their ways and don't have another option.
You know. If this falls I could teach, I got
a few college offers, I can teach somewhere.
If this falls, maybe I can become you know,
the new face of food trucks. It will be a
little sad and ironic [laughter]. You know
the irony is not fallen on me that, wow, I
could actually be, you know, a mega millionaire
off of something that I never.
>>[Interviewer]: Like the George Foreman grill?
Like, o my God, this is going to be my legacy?
But I'm not afraid and I think that people
that aren't not afraid to explore and see
what's out there those are the people that
are going to swim. But I wish those guys luck
with their endeavors, but you know, as an
artist they always ask "What advice do you
have for me?" My new advice is always have
a plan B.
>>[Interviewer]: Well it seems like a good
note to end on. ?uestlove, thank you.
>>[Ahmir]: Thank you.
>>[Interviewer]: So much, it was a pleasure.
>>